et pour approfondir le sujet nous
recevons alexis mohamed conseiller
spécial auprès du président de la
république de djibouti bonjour je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour parler de djibouti ce
lieu stratégique on vient de le voir
liés au détroit de bab el mandeb les
chinois sont donc les derniers à s'y
installer comment est-ce que vous
collaborez avec ces pays et les
avantages est-il pas écouté comme j'ai
toujours dit la ligue djibouti se veut
d'abord la petite suisse de l'afrique
donc c'est un pays qui est extrêmement
ouvert qui également qui a également
plusieurs histoires et aujourd'hui ça
nous pousse à nous ça nous cause aucun
problème d'avoir autant de partenaires
sur le territoire national comme vous
venez de le dire du boutis est vraiment
riche de multiples présence des amis
historiques qui sont là et je pense que
tout le monde y trouve son intérêt
politique économique etc
donc pour nous c'est vraiment une bonne
chose avant tout et que vient de trouver
les chinois alors qu'il ya un rappel
sont les derniers à s'intéresser de très
près à djibouti bah écoutez les chinois
s'inscrivent un peu comme les autres
partenaires parce que comme vous savez
sur la mer rouge vous avez autour de
passage du qui viennent du nord jusqu'en
asie je parle en fait de la marine
marchande
la chine et la présence chinoise en tout
cas où l'armée qui est là est tout
simplement dans les cadres de de la
protection de la sécurité pour ce qui
concerne leur propre
comment dirais-je marchand marine
marchande tout simplement ce n'est pas
dans les cas d'une stratégie militaire
ou quoi que ce soit c'est vraiment
danser car assez spécifique
plusieurs projets d'infrastructure
portait à part des intérêts français
sont jusque-là en stand by
c'est au profit justement des intérêts
asiatique français vous avez des jeunes
tricolores oui français les forces
militaires les infrastructures il ya
quelques projets d'infrastructure qui
sont en cours mais manifestement en
stand by
écoutez je
je l'apprends en même temps que vous
alors de projets d'infrastructure
puisqu'il concerne la france
néanmois je pense que la france est
toujours là c'est un allié vraiment
historique mais si elle a vraiment
aujourd'hui de deux projets
d'infrastructures en est on est vraiment
on en serait vraiment en tout cas ravi
qu'on le sache et voilà en tout cas ça
serait vraiment bien accueilli
alors il ya d'autres pays qui sont
intéressées par une implantation à
djibouti notamment l'arabie saoudite
c'est en pourparlers écoutez je
laisserais en tout cas le soin à notre
diplomatie étrangère de pouvoir se
prononcer là dessus pour le moment les
choses ne sont pas aussi concrète
quand le pense mais je pense que le le
les affaires étrangères c'est vraiment
mieux habilité en tout cas répondent à
cette question là il ya aussi ce projet
vision à 2035
qui entend faire de djibouti e
logistique régionale une place
financière et commerciale internationale
quels sont les atouts dont dispose
vimoutiers
pour atteindre cet objectif c'est vrai
que depuis en tout cas 99 depuis
l'élection présidentielle depuis en fait
l'arrivée du chef de l'état à la tête de
la république d du boutis effectivement
il ya cette ambition de devenir
aujourd'hui un hub régional est d'autant
plus il faut savoir qu est la république
des joutes et avant que la porte
d'entrée du marché de comesa une des
raisons pour laquelle je dire je
parlerai pas des risques mon tout cas où
le chef de l'état a trouvé vraiment
ingénieux de 2 comment dirais-je de
faire en sorte à ce que la république de
djibouti puisse jouer justement départ
son emplacement stratégique c'est rôle
de hub régional pour que en tout cas
nous puissions de notre côté également
développer tout ce qui a trait à la
question de l'employabilité donc
donc voilà il ya ces faits s est fait de
la porte d'accès ont fait au marché du
comesa qui est là c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle d'ailleurs aujourd'hui je
parlais justement de points stratégiques
ou d'emplacement et stratégiques
c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
aussi le monde aujourd'hui c'est
bousculent à du boutis vous avez parlé
du salaire des chinois les derniers
arrivés vous avez les américains les
français qui sont également là qui sont
des alliés historiques
vous avez les japonais de secteurs
accepta donc départ sans nom placement
historique effectivement du boutis
suscite beaucoup d'intérêt vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis du monde
mais malgré tout être la zone à risques
qui entourent la république de djibouti
ce que ce n'est pas là un frein
important pour faire de ce petit pays de
l'est de l'afrique une place commerciale
internationale
non je moi je pense qu'en fait la petite
instabilité actuellement par rapport à
la somalie je pense que vous parlez d ça
ne va pas te nullement en tout cas les
objectifs fixés par la république de
djibouti je pense que
la république de djibouti en soi est
vraiment sécurisée est vraiment stable
également
l'ethiopie effectivement il ya peut-être
quelques conflits sociaux mais c'est un
pays qui est resté quand même indéniable
moins stable je pense que la région la
sous région il ya est certaine il ya
vraiment aujourd'hui
cette stabilité là et sur lesquels je
pense beaucoup de gens essayent en tout
cas de mise et c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle d'ailleurs de la même
budget 8,6 et dans toute la région que
les monde aujourd'hui c'est bouscula
alors en quelques mots il ya aussi à
l'élection présidentielle qui approche
c'est pas pour tout de suite c'est pour
l'avs avril 2021 dans un peu plus d'un
an
à quels seront les enjeux en amont de
cette élection le scrutin dans le genre
les enjeux seront également le même
enjeu que le mandat précédent si bien
évidemment les chefs de l'état ses
représentants tout cas je lui laisse
je lui laisse effectivement le soin en
tout cas d'eceh prononcer sur cette
question là mais toujours est il que de
toute manière départ départ seul
engagement que ce soit dans les cadres
de la sécurité de la paix la stabilité
que ce soit au niveau national mon
niveau régional la pluie djibouti est un
fin connaisseur en tout cas aujourd'hui
à la fois des problématiques nos
concitoyens mais également de nos
partenaires frontaliers je pense en tout
cas que il serait judicieux en tout cas
pour ma part que les chefs des l'états
puissent se représenter afin de pouvoir
continuer en tout cas les oeuvres ou
l'oeuvre qu'il a comme on sait pas ce
qui concerne la question économique la
question sociale etc
c'est également l'ensemble des
engagements de nos forces armées dans la
région pour sur la question en tout cas
de la sécurité la stabilité d'ailleurs
je voudrais féliciter notre diplomatie
étrangère qui grâce à l'ensemble de son
travail a permis aujourd'hui à la
république de djibouti d'être élu pour
la deuxième fois au conseil de sécurité
de l'ap et de conseils en tout cas de
l'union africaine merci d'avoir plus le
temps de répondre à nos question annexe
i mohammed je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller spécial auprès du président
de la république de djibouti c'est moi
qui vous remercie